we carry a casino around in our pockets
24 7.
pandemic lockdowns and the cost of
living crisis have driven more people to
gambling to help ease Financial
struggles with helplines receiving
record-breaking calls for help
more than 400 000 British gamblers lose
at least 2 000 pounds a year so 75 of
our colors are actually citing financial
difficulties and an increasing number of
women are turning to betting they make
up a third of the callers to the
National gambling helpline gambling
costs our antidote homeless lost
everything more than one in ten of those
women are gambling to supplement
household incomes and their families but
how did they get into it in the first
place and what's being done to help them
I'm Kimberly Leonard infernil Patterson
and this is the Sky News Daily
I'll be speaking to a treatment manager
at one of the leading gambling Charities
about how women are struggling and the
support available but first Lisa Walker
she knows the devastation gambling
addiction can cause so I started to
gamble at quite a young age about eight
years old quite innocently and I was
taking on holiday to South End on say
whether it be penny alkai and I thought
about Mr bets at the two paid five
pounds Lisa now works as a peer support
worker for the charity bet no more and
runs their women-only program new
beginnings
put a bit on the Grand National perhaps
I spent 20 quid or two pound on a bet on
the Grand National so it wasn't
Epstein's problem but obviously yes the
years went on and you know the time went
on I did find fruit machines and
roulette roles and everything else that
went along with gambling but it wasn't
until I reached the age of 29 that I
sort of
became a compulsive Gambler where I
couldn't stop it's interesting that you
say you started gambling at eight
because one doesn't really associate
a kid in a in I suppose it's an arcade
as gambling
but unfortunately when you when I look
back even you know I can remember when I
was eight years old trying to be arcades
and getting my part of two pays and
pushing the two keys out and I remember
sort of getting excited when they used
to drop such a young age and then
watching my dad on the fruit of the
chains and sort of like the age of sort
of 10 11 now in acts like I have broken
shame I didn't know that you know my dad
had a problem again believe because I
was young I didn't you know I didn't
guarantee in my late a lot so for you
when did gambling
really start to become a bigger issue in
your life and a problem when I had the
huge win I was 29 years old and I won
six figures some you know life changing
money unfortunately looking back it was
the worst thing that possibly could have
ever happened to me because that was the
day that everything changed because once
I won that money
I thought I could win it again and it
sort of led me into our bath I sort of
really got in the gambling and started
grinding out front machines roulette
valuable Blackjack quadca the higher
amount donated bookmakers dog where I
was seeing horse racing
you're Naomi I was addicted to it how
much of your day Lisa did you spend
gambling I suppose from the age of 29 to
45.
again well probably every day some days
it would just be an hour
some weekend but again Bowl
10 12 hours in the casino from long
until night or night till long then
depending on if I have my children or
not and if I could get out you know I
lost so much time so I'm never ever
going to get back
so what eventually happened what did
your gambling cost you my children Now
26 and 27 years old now
um so when they were 10 and 11 gambling
cost me my house so I ended up homeless
lost everything you know I went to my
local Council felt so much
shame and guilt and stigma around my
gambling I was um
I was meant to feel like
I was afrailed there wasn't the help out
there that I needed gambling cost me my
marriage and obviously out of my husband
and yeah and it led me to some very very
deep dark places can you just explain
that a bit more when you went to the
council and asked for help you've lost
your home you've got these two kids 10
and 11 and they made you feel like a
fraud this was 15 years ago so I went up
to the council with my children and I
was interviewed by a housing officer
when they found out that I'd gambled my
money away and lost a lot of money I was
told that if I'd have been a drug
athlete or an alcoholic I could have
pointed me in the right direction for
help but what are they supposed to do
with the compulsory Gambler and almost
sort of lie the the Gill and the blind
that I felt in the room that day I'll
never forget ever
you know I feel so long uh so lonely so
I actually like me
and thinking
why doesn't anybody understand that oh
I've got on addictions to gambling and I
need help I haven't done it on purpose
I've lost this money on purpose you know
I just need to be signposted with
someone that can help me and now one did
five years ago I got married in Vegas my
current husband who was in the capital
city you know the world began Berlin I
let my wedding party say
uh to go and Gamble and uh that's what I
did all night I took a payday loan which
was words my bank account from England
and so like again bowl and have the fans
to do it
and then
you know sort of like the next day uh
the day after my wedding I started my
marriage off on a lie did your husband
know what you were doing yeah so me and
my husband met nine years ago he knew my
story
but again I'm a compulsive again blah
and put it lying I'm good at hiding
things so he thought that I was just
going to stay now once awake to playing
my poker which I was but unfortunately
once I got knocked back to Poker
competition I was going next door into
the casino where they had all the tables
like the roulette and the Black Jack and
it was broke the chains and and I was
taking out credit cards payday loans so
we got back from Vegas and
um I had to pay this 2 000 pound back
that I've borrowed it was a very very
high interest as well because I was
bankrupt as well at the time and I
needed this 2 000 pounds so I reached
out to my son who was 21 at the time
and uh said Laura could you lender this
Monday and he did transferred it from my
can thinking you know that I was going
to pay it off
and I didn't I went into the book bikers
where I leave and within 35 minutes up
into two thousand pounds and that's when
I know
that is when I hit rock bottom so what
did you do and where did you get that
help so I reached out to a friend that
was in gamblies Anonymous and he tells
me that I need to get to a meeting this
was my third attempt at gambler's
anonymous
and he told them to get back and he told
me that this time I've got to listen
because they weren't going to be any
more chancy because I'd already lost my
home and the next thing relay is death
because there's nothing else because I
will show up button so I went to GI
there was 35 Main and one other woman
and I sat there helped my story I got
home that night
and I arranged for a big fan in meeting
and just
after everything everything like ma
everything out on table said to end that
I need help I'm a compulsive fan below
my son listen to me and uh said Lord you
know we're going to get through it
touchwood and they are I've been bet
through that's fantastic and you'll now
appear support worker in the sector just
tell us a bit more about the program
that you run so I want to run a 10-week
program now called New Beginning for
women only and they come in and we talk
about different subjects every week
after the 10 weeks that we mean are then
referred to our health and well-being
groups that we run because I've always
said that you don't have an addiction
for 10 weeks and addiction is a lifelong
program and I know that I've got a card
to GA for the rest of my life yeah the
women that come in are pretty much Rock
Bottom because I'd feel like there isn't
any else there's no other women
until they come in and make up a relief
at all and then they realize they're not
alone
when people need support with their
gambling addiction they might come
across someone like Lisa Patton a
treatment service manager at the charity
gam care I have a team who support
people with gambling issues and they're
affected others we offer CBT based
therapy to support people to see
alternative ways of not gambling and
promoting healthier Lifestyles then
January we had a record number of calls
sir helpline it was up 17 on the January
of 2022 that can be a combination of
things off of the back of the World Cup
Christmas obviously ill Chester bills
gas bills are increasing so 75 of our
callers are actually citing financial
difficulties we will find people are
bored they're isolated they are chasing
losses so they might have had a big win
previously it's very accessible through
the internet or on the phone and they
have bills to pay they've got children
to feed and it's trying to make that
money up that they might have
potentially lost previously and are you
seeing more women who need access to
help yes and nobody would like more
women to come forward as a very hidden
addiction we talk about in gambling at
UCF Behavior change if it's alcohol or
drugs but with gambling I could be
sitting on the train with you or on a
bus and you wouldn't know you would
think I was texting whereas I actually
could be gambling so it is very hidden
and there's a lot of Shame and guilt
particularly around women for them when
they are when they're gambling actually
to admit it I think we look to to women
to be like households sometimes to be
like the breadwinner that keeps it all
together and it can be partly escapism
from from daily life it could be mental
health issues that they're experiencing
so that's where you can go away and you
can you can gamble to escape Escape
those kind of daily daily things that
are going on in your life and it's
taking that first step and and saying
there is no shame there is no guilt that
I am gambling it's not any different to
whether I would be smoking or drinking
or taking drugs as an addiction and it's
it's how do how do we support women best
to feel safe in safe spaces other places
that women tend to find there's a lot of
male dominated spaces so they don't feel
comfortable and how has it changed since
the pandemic just in general the
gambling World women seeking help men
seeking help how has it changed
obviously unfortunately like a lot of
people had to to go back into their
houses so potentially women particularly
around domestic abuse we're back going
back into that space so it's that safety
again A lot of people are in their house
they're bored and we have very much
we've moved online ever since online now
and advertising is all online you're
presented with that every day you
mentioned the cost of living crisis and
how it's affected people you said that
people are turning to gambling to earn
an extra Buck but do they actually make
money or do you end up losing more money
than you actually started out with they
end up losing more money but in in their
history you think that they are making
more money and that's why we talk about
chasing losses and the cost of living
crisis has increased people looking for
support around that to make that money
up but to be thinking their heads that
they're going to win when when they're
not but the majority of other women are
all online gambling so we very much
stereotype women to bingo halls and men
to Bookies but actually we tend to find
that it's online gambling and scratch
cards as well are prevalent as well
where it's a quick easy fix you're
looking for that Adrenaline Rush the
brain does change when when you're
chasing and chasing that win so what do
you do if you need support where do you
go it's all we would encourage people
particularly to call our national
helpline which is 24 hours a day seven
days a week so we have trained advisors
there who are they're sitting just now
waiting to take your call we work
alongside them to make them feel
comfortable that may be the first time
and and that's it sounds scary for
people because as I said it's a very
secretive addiction but there will be no
judgment from us
[Music]
now a former Gambler Lisa wants to share
her story as a lesson for others
I think people say the cost of living
crisis and obviously it is a crisis gas
electric food petrol everything's bowing
out and I think people are sort of like
betting 10 or 20 quid to try to win 40
or 50 pounds perhaps to help with their
shopping and they're obviously getting
reeled in
um by some of the operators that are
offering free bets free Spin sign up
offers and I've just died just be really
really careful when people think listen
let me just put 10 pounds down because I
need 50 pounds just to cover the
shopping
it really works out like that doesn't it
you often end up losing well yeah you do
but obviously if you if you do bet 10
pounds and you do with 50 pounds your
office should shortly parents in profit
now some people might think wow that was
easy I've just made 40 creating two
minutes or 10 minutes how easy was that
for now I might put that 40 quid to try
to win a hundred pounds
and then it's like the snag ball effect
it's like the Vicious Circle you know
and it's just making sure that you've
got your boundaries in place that you
you know that you don't bet more than
you can afford loans
if you're concerned about your own
gambling or that of a loved one you can
contact the National gambling helpline
on 0808
8020133 and they're available 24 hours a
day seven days a week
my thanks to Lisa Walker and Lisa Patton
and to you for tuning in to the Sky News
Daily with me Kimberly Leonard this
episode was produced by Sola aparicio
and the editor is Philly Beaumont